good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today's message is break the rules over
to you George st. Pierre I never been
afraid to break the rules in life I'm
not talking about break the love
break the rules why would you want to be
in this in this world it's to be a like
everybody else the most successful
people is I are the one that are doing
things out there thinking outside of the
box so don't be afraid to break the
rules so I've never been a huge fan of
rules and I'm guessing if you're an
entrepreneur and you're watching this
channel you're not a big fan of rules
either arch burns in general we are rule
breakers we like to create new things we
like to push the boundaries we want to
change the way things are done in our
industry and so for that to happen we
have to break some of the rules I think
the rules are important and just to
understand that wolves are here to keep
average people doing average things and
there's a lot of things in life that you
are average at most things you're
average or maybe even below average in
life act and so the rules can help you
the rules can help you stay safe the
rules can help you get by you know if
you're in the emergency exit of an
airplane they have rules that you're
supposed to abide by unless you're an
airline security expert like follow the
rules the mask comes down put it on your
face right like there are rules to
follow that if you don't know anything
better just follow the rules it will
help keep you on the average but for the
things that you're way above average on
so the things that you have genius level
talent at and you be one of the best in
the world at for those things then you
have to adopt the mentality of I'm going
to break the rules
this is great clip of Steve Jobs who was
doing an interview and he's talking
about how the world is made up by people
who are no smarter than you the rules
that are in place were put there by
another human being who's no smarter
than you and if you are an expert in
your industry you're probably smarter
than them and so don't live your life
and run your business according to rules
that are old and created by people who
aren't as much of an expert as you are I
think a lot of people are afraid to
break a rule because that's the way that
it's always done and I'm not suggesting
you go out and do something that's
illegal because that's a whole other can
of worms but the way things are
traditionally done in an industry a lot
of times doesn't even make sense anymore
and that's on you to not just break the
rules but to create the new standard so
I looked at my youtube channel I just
came back from clammer Khan as an
example which is an event for youtubers
a lot of these guys are publishing one
video a week or video every two weeks
and part of the YouTube algorithm that's
really important is consistent content
once a day is really going to be the
minimum when I went from once a week to
once a day my channel shut up when I
went from once a day to twice a day my
channel shut up again I'm twice a day
three times a day
not as much doesn't really make a huge
shift and this still goes up but you
don't get the same returns as the other
one and so everybody is saying wow like
I don't know how you do it I don't know
how you how you build up that team and
you know and we're responding to every
single comment and we're updating our
tags and descriptions and titles and
testing thumbnails and doing all these
things that most people aren't doing on
YouTube and that's why I've had the
success that other people haven't and so
it's setting a new standard right
breaking the rules that people thought
were important before and say no this is
a new path to go and come and follow me
and I think if you have that ability you
have that genius level talented
something you are the expert in your
industry it's not only it's not only
what you should be doing for yourself
it's your your obligation to go out and
create a new standard for your industry
and not play to a smaller level it's
because there are some rules
place so the question date today is I'm
curious what is the single biggest rule
that you want to break in your industry
what's the rule that drives you nuts
that you want to abolish and say this is
the new way I'm curious leave it down
the comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to Diana Gartland from
Dana Gartland calm thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your
one-word Diana I really really really
appreciate it and I hope you're enjoying
the read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I
will see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events presto
we have so many rules in life about
everything as they break the rules not
the law but break the rules my wife has
a t-shirt my wife has a t-shirt that
says well-behaved women rarely make
history well you know I don't want to
burst a bubble but the same is true with
man it is impossible to be a maverick or
true original if you're too well behaved
and don't want to break the rules you
have to think outside the box that's
what I believe after all what is the
point of being on this earth if all you
want to do is delight for everyone and
avoid trouble the only way that ever got
any place was the breaking some of the
rules after all I remember that after I
was finished with my bodybuilding career
I wanted to get into acting and want to
be a star in films you can imagine what
the agent said when I went to meet all
those agents everyone has the same line
that it can't be done the rules are
different here just look at your body
hear this huge monstrous body it overly
developed it doesn't fit into the movies
you don't understand this was 20 years
ago the Hercules movies now there is the
little guys that ain't Dustin Hoffman
Woody Allen Chuck Nicholson before he
came wait of course that is but anyway
those are the guys that Wayne and the
agent also complained about Max and he
says no one ever became a star with an
accent like that especially not with the
German accent in yes I can imagine with
your name Arnold Schwarzenegger or
whatever the name is on a billboard yeah
that's going to draw a lot of tickets
and sell a lot of tickets you're right
so this is the kind of negative attitude
they have but I didn't listen to those
rules even though they were very nice
and they said look we can get you some
big parts we can they get you to be a
you know being a wrestler or bouncer oh
maybe the German accent we can get it to
be a Nazi officer in Hogan's Heroes or
something like that but you know I
didn't listen to all that this was their
rules
not my rules I was convinced that could
do it that if I worked as hard as I did
in bodybuilding five hours a day and I
started getting the work I started
taking acting classes took English
classes took speech classes
dialogue classes
accident removal classes are even took I
remember running around a fine wine
grows on a vine because Germans had
difficulties with the F and the W and
the V so fine wine grows in the vine I
know what some of you now say is I hope
that Arnold got his money back but let
me tell you something I had a good time
doing those things and it really helped
me finally I broke through
I broke through and I started getting
the first parts in TV streets of San
Francisco Lucille Ball hired me and made
pumping arms stay hungry and then I got
the big break in Conan the Barbarian and
they are the director said if we
wouldn't have Schwarzenegger we would
have to build one now think about that
and then when a determinate ER I'll be
back became most of one of the most
famous lines in a movie history all
because of my crazy actions now think
about it the things that the agent said
will be totally a detriment and will be
impossible for me to get a job all of a
sudden became an asset for me all of the
things my accent the body and everything
so just so you never lose that it can't
do something and you have to work your
way up of course run for something else
first I mean it was the same in in when
I ran for governor the same lines that
if the rug you wrap it can't be done and
then of course I ran for governor and
the rest of course is history they said
you have to start with a small Chiapas
mayor and then there's a simply man and
then the attendant governor and then as
governor and they said that's the way it
works in a political career I said I'm
not interested in the political career I
want to be a public servant I want to
fix California's problems and bring
people together and bring the parties
together so like I said I decided to run
I didn't pay attention to the rules and
I made it in the rest is history
let me tell you a story so a friend of
mine and I we went for a run in Central
Park the Roadrunners organization on the
weekends they host races and it's very
common at the end of the race they'll
have a sponsor who will give away
something
apples or bagels or something and on
this particular day when we got to the
end of the run
there were some free bagels and they had
picnic tables set up and on one side was
a group of volunteers on the table were
boxes of bagels and on the other side
was a long line of runners waiting to
get their free bagel so I said to my
friend let's let's get a bagel and he
looked at me and said that lines too
long and I said free bagels
and he said I don't want to wait in line
and I was like free bagel and he says
not it's too long and that's when I
realized that there's two ways to see
the world some people see the thing that
they want and some people see the thing
that prevents them from getting the
thing that they want I could only see
the bagels he could only see the line
and so I walked up to the line I leaned
in between two people put my hand in the
box and pulled out two bagels and no one
get mad at me because the rule is you
can go after whatever you want
you just cannot deny anyone else to go
after whatever they want
now I had to sacrifice choice I didn't
get to choose which bagel I got I got
whatever I pulled out but I didn't have
to wait in line so the point is is you
don't have to wait in line you don't
have to do it the way everybody else has
done it you can do your way you can
break the rules you just can't get in
the way of somebody else getting what
they want
that's rule number one